write 14897
in expanded form so let me just rewrite
the number and i'll color code it and
that way we can keep track of our digits
so we have 14 000. so one
yeah i don't have to write well let me
write it that big fourteen thousand
fourteen thousand
eight hundred
eight hundred and ninety
and
ninety seven let's see i already used
the blue
maybe i should use yellow and 97 in
expanded form so let's think about what
place each of these digits are in this
right here the seven is in the ones
place this is in the ones place
this is in the ones place the nine is in
the tens place
the nine is in the tens place this
literally represents nine tens and we're
going to see this in a second this
literally represents seven ones
the eight is in the hundreds place
this is in the hundreds place
the four is in the thousands place it
literally represents four thousand
so this is in the thousands
place and then the one is in the ten
thousands place
is in the ten thousands
place and you see every time you move to
the left you move one place to the left
you're multiplying by ten ones place
tens place hundreds place thousands
place ten thousands place now let's
think about what that really means if
this one is in the ten thousands place
that means that it literally means it
literally represents so this one
literally represents i want to do this
in a way that my arrows don't get mixed
up actually let me start at the other
end let me start with the seven
represents the seven literally
represents
seven
ones
seven ones or another way to think about
it it also you could say it represents
seven
times one all of these are equivalent it
represents seven ones now let's think
about the nine that's why i'm doing it
from the right so that the arrows don't
have to cross each other
so what does the nine represent it
represents
nine
tens
you could literally imagine you have
nine actual tens you could have a ten
plus a ten plus a ten do that nine times
that's literally what it represents nine
actual tens nine tens or you could say
it's the same thing as nine times ten or
ninety either way you wanna think about
it so let me write all the different
ways to think about it or ninety it
represents all of these things nine tens
or nine times ten or
ninety so then we have our eight
our eight
represents we see it's in the hundreds
place it represents eight hundreds
eight hundreds
or you could view that as being
equivalent to eight times one hundred
a hundred not a thousand eight times a
hundred or
eight hundred that eight literally
represents eight hundreds eight hundred
and then the four
i think you get the idea here this
represents in the thousands place it
represents four thousands
four thousands which is the same thing
as four times one thousand which is the
same thing as four thousand four
thousand is the same thing as four
thousands added up
and then finally we have this one which
is sitting in the ten thousands place so
it literally represents one
10
ten thousand
ten thousand
one ten thousand or you could imagine it
you can imagine if these were kind of
chips kind of poker chips that would
represent one of the blue poker chip and
each blue poker chip represents ten
thousand i don't know if that helps you
or not and one ten thousand same thing
as one times ten thousand
which is the same thing as ten thousand
so when they ask us to write it in
expanded form we could write fourteen
thousand 14897 literally as the sum of
these numbers of kind of its components
or we could write as the sum of these
numbers and actually let me write this
this top 7 times 1 is just equal to 7.
so
14897 is the same thing as ten thousand
ten thousand
plus four thousand
plus four thousand
plus
eight hundred eight hundred
plus 800
plus 90 that's the 90 or 90
plus 90
plus seven
plus
seven so you could consider this
expanded form or you could use this
version of it or you could say this is
the same thing as
one times ten thousand depending on what
people consider to be expanded form plus
four times
four times one thousand
plus
eight times a hundred eight times one
hundred
plus nine times ten
plus
nine times ten plus seven times one
scroll to the right a little bit
plus
seven times one so either of these could
be considered expanded form